[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: Take a moment
to look around you.
Look at the person
on your right.
Now look at the
person on your left.
Turn around and look behind
you and in front of you.
If you have a question
on mathematics,
or you want to know something
about the potential new
elements in the
cosmic dust of space,
or perhaps you want
to know something
about the architecture of
the most beautiful bridge
in the world, the Millau
Bridge in southwestern France,
chances are there is
a good possibility
that someone in
this class may be
able to answer your question.
There are 11 different
majors in this small class.
This presents a great
opportunity for you
to actually mingle with these
majors and broaden your ideas.
Welcome to 5.310.
5.310 is a non-major sequence
in the chemistry department.
In chemistry, in MIT
lingo actually, this
is a 2-8-2 course.
12 credits.
In MIT policies,
one credit unit is
14 hours of work per semester.
So if we look at
this, we've actually
got 28 hours of lecture,
112 hours of lab,
and 28 hours of outside work
for a total of 168 hours.
But you really only have--
you're really only
going to be in lecture
for 17 of those hours.
And there are five labs.
Each lab is four days.
That's 20 days times
4 hours is 80 hours.
One of the labs is five days
so that's 84 hours of lab.
This outside work is on the low
side so I'm going to fix it.
I'm going to
increase that to 50.
Does that make you feel good?
We're moving some
hours around here.
And there's one more thing.
17 hours of lecture but
three of the labs on day four
you get out right
after the quiz.
You can finish the
experiment in three days.
I know.
You're all excited
about that, right?
So we're really only talking
74 hours in lab here.
So I'm going to
increase this to 60.
So we end up with 151 hours.
If you subtract those, you
have a surplus of 17 hours.
So I just want you to see this
so that you feel good about it
and you know you're not--
if you look at this
and do the calculation,
you're going to be spending
between 10 and 11 hours a week
in this course.
And on the long side, if
you use these surplus hours,
you'll be at the
12 credit units.
Now take a look at this
slide for a moment.
If you look at the slide,
you can see that 5.310 ties
in to 5.35.
5.35, six, seven, and eight
are the URIECA modules,
Undergraduate Research
Inspired Experimental Chemistry
Alternatives.
I got it all out.
OK.
Good.
So we've got 12 labs here.
Each lab is
approximately four units.
And what happens is 5.310
ties into those labs.
Those are the labs that
the chem majors take.
So what that means is
if you're a freshman,
if you're a sophomore
or a junior,
and you suddenly decide that
you like chemistry and you want
to change your major, or
you want to double major,
I'll give you full credit
for 5.35 after taking 5.310.
So you'll eliminate
three of those modules
from your program.
It's a good deal.
Now let's talk a little
bit about the course.
So is this course
useful to my future?
It is an introductory
laboratory chemistry course.
But you will learn
basic skills that you'll
be able to carry away with you
for the rest of your tenure
at MIT and beyond MIT.
What you're going to
learn in this course--
you'll learn about
small scale synthesis.
You'll learn about inert
atmosphere techniques,
thin layer chromatography
and column chromatography.
You'll do an atmospheric
distillation and a vacuum
distillation.
You'll also operate a
variety of instruments.
And these are the most
modern instruments
that you're going to
find in pharma companies,
in chemical companies, and
industry when you go out.
You'll be operating things like
polarimeters, refractometers,
density meters.
You'll operate a tabletop
nuclear magnetic resonance
spectrometer, 60
megahertz just for you.
You'll operate a robotic
GC, an IR spectrometer,
UV spectrometer, and
a mass spectrometer.
You'll also get to put
your samples in and watch
an inductively coupled plasma
mass spectrometer running.
There's only two at MIT.
And you also will go to
the X-ray lab here at MIT.
And you'll see the most
modern X-ray diffraction
machine from Germany
running some of your samples
from the essential oils lab.
In one part of the lab,
you'll go on a field trip
to the Charles River.
Can take your lunch.
You're going to bring
back water samples.
You'll be testing those water
samples for dissolved oxygen
and phosphate levels.
Above all these
things, you're going
to learn organizational
skills that you'll
have with you for the rest of
your career wherever you go.
Can you give me any hot tips?
Students always
ask for a hot tip.
And I can tell you one thing
that actually works for me.
And that is sometimes we all
get frustrated and discouraged.
And when that happens, I
usually find a quiet place
and I talk to my brain.
And I tell my brain
everything is OK.
Everything is going to be fine.
And time and time again,
this works for me.
I can get myself out of it.
And if you read Oliver
Sachs, in one of his books,
he says that if you
can imagine things,
they actually can
turn into reality.
So are there any brain and
cognitive science folks?
Oh good.
Look at this.
I've got four of them.
Can any of you offer any
comments on how this helps me?
Is there something there?
Anyone?
No takers.
Anyone else?
So I guess the
thinking about, you
must become happier and
clear your thoughts out.
And if you become happier
and clear your thoughts,
you become smarter too.
Right?
And I actually
brought a brain that I
keep in my refrigerator,
a beautiful brain.
And I'm just going to set it
here so that you can admire it.
So the brain is very important.
Some of you in this course
are very, very smart.
You're all very
smart because you
got into MIT or at
the top of your class.
You're valedictorians.
I recall several years
ago I had a freshman
advisee who came to me.
And she actually tested
out of every subject.
She sat down and I
could not find one
subject to put this student in.
So I was kind of beside myself.
I went out of my
office and I bumped
into the head of the
physics department
walking down the hall and
said, I've got this advisee
and I don't know what to do.
Did you ever have one like this?
He said once every 10 years.
So I went back and I put her
into all the most advanced
classes, some with
graduate students.
And then I ask her
how she managed
to do all this because she came
from an island in the Pacific.
And she said to me
OCW, OpenCourseWare.
I watched the lectures
that MIT puts out
and I learned it all myself.
But there are geniuses
sprinkled throughout MIT.
And there are probably
geniuses in this class.
Should you still take 5.310?
Yes, because geniuses
need practical skills.
And in 5.310 can help you
to bind those basic skills
and make your genius
become reality.
Now there are a couple
other key things
to help you succeed
in this course.
One, if you feel
like you need help
and you don't know what to do,
you're lost, come to see us.
And we'll get you back on track.
The second thing,
which is important,
is you need to be able
to accept your mistakes.
If you make a mistake,
don't start crying and say
it's all over.
I blew this lab.
I just messed everything up.
I'm done for here.
I don't know what to do.
Just accept the mistake
and ask yourself,
what can I get out of
this mistake that I made.
And when you do that, you
really can help yourself
for the long term.
I mean it's not anything
embarrassing if a student works
for three days and
then, by accident,
they drop their product.
It happens.
So don't feel bad about it.
Just come to us and
we'll work something out.
But don't get
stressed out over it.
The last thing that
could really help you
here is, in this class,
it's all about lab reports.
So you've got to write
these four lab reports
and give an oral
report at the end.
My advice to you is don't
wait until the last day
of the last weekend when these
reports are due to actually try
to write this report out.
Start early.
When you're in the
lab, a four hour
lab, and a lot of
those labs you'll
get done at four so
you'll have an hour.
We have beautiful write up
areas in the new undergraduate
chemistry lab.
You can sit there.
And that's the point where
you can actually write out
a paragraph about what you did
that day, what you actually
did, what you saw,
and what you found.
And that's your procedure
and observations
for your lab report.
And while it's fresh in
your mind, you do it.
And the procedure and
observations typically
is about a page and a half,
no more than two pages,
of your lab report.
You could also work on the
background of the report
because you're talking
about why you're
doing this experiment, what
you're going to get out
of it, something about the
history of the experiment, what
was done before.
So you can work on these
sections along the way
rather than wait until the very
end and do a marathon session,
try to trying to get
the lab report done.
So with those things, I'd
like to talk a little bit
about the course.
And I'm going to cover
seven broad areas.
One is academic integrity.
The second thing
is the lab policies
and then, most
importantly, grading,
how this course will be graded.
And then we'll look a
little bit at safety,
because you do have a safety
lecture you're going to.
And we'll look a little bit
at the lab notebooks that
are required for the course.
And we'll talk a little
bit about waste management.
And finally, we'll
spend a little bit
of time talking about
calibration of instruments.
So let's start with
academic honesty.
MIT has one of the
best integrity programs
of any school that I know.
They have a website
devoted to it.
They also have printed
material that you can pick up
and you can read through it.
And I think probably
to summarize it
in just one sentence, you don't
want to present as your work
the efforts and product
of another person.
And the penalties
can be quite severe.
You could actually
fail the assignment.
Could fail the course.
You could be suspended
from the Institute.
You could even
forfeit your degree.
So it's pretty serious business.
In 5.310, I think there are two
areas that you need to actually
look at.
One of them is there are a
lot of lab reports out there.
They're in the dorms.
And they're in the
sororities and fraternities.
And they call them bibles.
So you don't want to actually
go out and take pieces out
of those and put them
in your own reports.
The reason for that is
it's not right to do that.
And the second
reason is we could
have an electronic copy of
one of those reports on file.
That would not be good.
The other thing is I guess
the innocent thing is
when students sit down
together and they're
talking about the lab.
You might talk with
your lab partner.
You can talk and you're
writing things down.
But what you don't want
to end up happening
is you don't want to have the
same sentences in both lab
reports.
So you've got to put
things in your own words
even when you talk
with each other
and you're writing
your reports up.
That's pretty much all I have
to say about academic integrity.
S the undergraduate
lab policies--
you're actually picking to
work on either Monday/Wednesday
or Tuesday/Thursday.
And depending on the safety
lecture that you elected,
some of you went yesterday
to the safety lecture
and you enrolled in the
Monday/Wednesday section.
Today the safety lecture is at 1
o'clock right after this class.
And Tuesday/Thursday people
will go there, attend the safety
lecture, and then
you'll go up to lab
to check in your lockers.
If there are any
Tuesday/Thursday people who
would like to switch
to Monday/Wednesday,
Monday/Wednesday will
have fewer students.
So there'll be much better
TA interaction with you.
So if you can, just
let Sarah know.
She'll be down
front at 1 o'clock
registering you
for your lockers.
And if you'd like to
do Monday/Wednesday,
you can check in today.
We'll just give you a
Monday/Wednesday locker.
The lab itself opens
at 1 o'clock every day.
And the TAs will give a
pre-lab lecture at 1:05.
It's about a 20 minute lecture.
It's going to cover
exactly what you're
doing in that four hour period.
And they will also demonstrate
some of the glassware, maybe
the pipettes, and
anything you're
going to be using in that lab.
And they'll also show
you the instruments
that you might be
running that day.
So it's pretty important,
the pre-lab lecture.
And it will also firm up
what you heard in the lecture
and possibly didn't
understand something,
your TAs can really
help in that respect.
On the fourth lab day of each
experiment, there's a quiz.
And that will cover--
you've already done the
three days of the experiment
so you should be in pretty
good shape for the quiz.
You should understand what
you're doing and know.
You shouldn't have
any problem with that.
The laboratory, we try to
clean up about quarter to 5:00.
I can't recall in 5.310 any
time where students have to stay
after 5 o'clock.
That's a good thing because
you want to go home.
Some of you have sport practice.
And we understand that.
And the last thing is we've
indicated some select Fridays
that are make-up labs.
And there will be one Friday
at the end of each four day lab
period.
So if for some reason
you've missed something
because you're sick and you
couldn't do it on day four,
then we have that option.
And those are scheduled in the
lab syllabus in your packets.
Safety goggles.
You have to buy these
at the VWR stockroom,
the basement of building 56.
And I mean, you put these on
and they actually really--
they hug your face.
They don't look too
glamorous, but you're not
going to a beauty contest.
You're going to the lab.
But you've got to
buy a pair of these.
And you've got to wear
them at all times.
The other thing is your lab coat
is a fire-resistant lab coat.
These are top of
the line lab coats.
We issue you one of
these when you come.
We'll also give you
a baggy like this.
And you can write
your name on the bag
and hang it in your
locker and leave it there.
You never take it
out of the lab.
You leave it there.
And first thing you do when you
come in, at either entrance,
either from building
13 or building 16
when you enter building
12, you'll have lockers.
And you can grab your lab
coat and goggles, put them on,
and you'll be ready for the lab.
We've got plenty of gloves.
We use nitrile gloves.
And generally, those gloves do
not give students any problems.
But if you have an issue
with that, just let us know.
The attire.
So the lab coats have
to be worn at all times.
And you can't wear-- you can't
come in with open-toed shoes,
low cut jeans, t-shirts.
You have to be really covered.
So my suggestion
is that you bring
a little bag, a
change of clothes,
and you keep it in the locker.
Students did this last semester.
It worked really well.
And then you can just change
out and change out again
when you're leaving.
And that way you can wear
your sandals, and your shorts,
and anything you want, but you
can't wear that in the lab.
Cell phones, radios, iPods.
You have to keep those
in your backpacks.
And this is what the lockers
look like at the entryway.
So you just grab one of those.
And that'll become your locker.
Once you hang your
lab coat in there,
no one else is going to
put anything in there.
And we've never had any
problems with the lockers
in the undergraduate lab.
If you want to put a lock on
your locker for the semester,
that's fine with me.
Obviously, no eating
and drinking in the lab.
You can't bring beverages
and food into the lab.
There are chemicals on the
countertops and around that you
just--
chemicals and food
just don't mix.
This is very important.
Report any accidents
or injuries promptly.
So if you do get cut or you
spill a chemical on yourself,
you should tell us.
If you leave the lab and then a
couple of days later come back
and you've broken out in a
red rash on your legs or arms,
it's much harder for
us to go back and try
to figure out what happened.
But if you tell us right away,
then we can track it down.
We know what chemical it was.
We know how to treat it.
And MIT Health will
help with that.
If you need special
accommodations
or you've got medical
conditions that you
would like to talk about, you
can come and see me on that.
And you should do it this week
just so we're aware of it.
And I mean we don't want--
we had a student
about three years ago
who just passed out in the lab.
I mean literally
down on the floor.
She was out.
And if we know ahead
of time if there
is a condition or something
that we should be aware of,
we can know better
how to treat that.
Grading.
This is the grading scale.
Pretty traditional.
It's not inflated
and it's not curved.
So it's a traditional
grading scale.
And this is what
we use in 5.310.
So the grading is all
based on five labs.
Each lab is worth 100 points.
Total number of points
is 500 for the course.
And this will make you happy.
There's no final exam.
There was a final
exam when I took over
this course 10 years ago.
But I got rid of it.
It was not nice.
So you've got 500 points.
And how is that broken down?
So of that 100 points, 20 points
is your quiz that you'll take.
So that incorporates into that.
Then you have your
pre-lab notebook
and your post-lab notebook.
That's 10 points.
Then there are 5
points which are
noted as discretionary
points for the TA.
And that would be like does
this student show up on time.
Does the student clean up their
area at the end of the lab?
Does the student wear
their safety glasses
or do they walk around with
the glasses up in the air?
So that's important.
And then your lab report,
either written or oral,
would be 65 points.
I'll show you this is
the course textbook.
This is the book that we
recommend that you get.
It's Mohrig.
and it's Laboratory Techniques
in Organic Chemistry.
Very good book.
It has chapters on all
of the instrumentation
and a lot of the techniques
that you'll be actually using
in the course.
Well worth to buy this book.
The other book that is not
required but it's on reserve
and we have copies in the
lab is this ACS style guide.
This will help you in terms of
writing up your lab reports,
writing up the
reference section,
knowing how correctly
to put things together.
Attendance.
Attendance is not
mandatory for this class.
But there is an attendance
sheet going around.
And each lecture day
we will send it around.
If you don't attend
lecture, your grade
isn't going to be penalized.
But if you do attend
all of the lectures,
at the end of the semester,
if your grade somehow
is within a half a
point of a higher grade,
89.5, technically
you'd get a B plus,
we'll look at the
lecture attendance
and that grade could be
pushed up to an A minus.
So that's how the
lecture attendance
works into this system.
And if you have any questions
as I'm going along, just ask.
So to get a passing
grade in 5.310,
you need to turn in the four
written reports and you need
to deliver the oral report.
There are some penalties.
So for a late lab, we
use three times n minus 1
plus 2, where n equals the
number of days the lab is late.
Also, with each lab, you
need to attach a cover sheet
to your written lab.
No cover sheet is
minus 2 points.
There are also some late
points on the oral report.
If you're late for an oral
report, it's minus five points.
If it has to be
rescheduled, it's
minus 10 points, just so you're
aware of the late points.
You don't want to use
these if you don't have to.
You really want to try to
turn your labs in on time.
And that two points
or five points
could make a big
difference at the end.
So this is the hard copy
of the course manual.
And you'll be allowed to
bring this in with you to lab.
You don't have to write up
the pre-lab step by step
that you're going to do.
You can bring this
in and follow it.
So we're saving you a
couple hours a week here.
I hope you appreciate that.
Students used to have to write
the pre-lab out step by step
in their own words.
So this is a big
time saver for you.
I want to keep this course
under that 12 credit limits.
You will need a lab notebook.
And the lab notebooks are
available either at the MIT
Coop or they have them
at the VWR stock room.
And they're around $15.
And the notebook should be
like 100 duplicate pages
with carbonless paper because
what's going to happen
is each day you go to lab, the
TA will initial your pre-lab.
And then at the end of
lab, you'll go to the TA
with your notebook.
And the TA will initial each
page of your post-lab notes.
Then you'll tear them all
out and hand them to your TA.
You keep the original.
We get the copy.
The reason for that is when
it comes down to the final lab
report, you cannot have anything
in the lab report that's not
in your post-lab notes
in your notebook.
So let's just take a
quick look and see.
For the pre-lab, this
is pretty simple.
You don't have to write
out the whole procedure,
but you do need to
have your title, date,
the name of the experiment,
an introduction, a couple
of sentences what this
experiment is about,
what you hope to get out of
it, maybe a couple of sentences
on safety issues that you
spotted in the experiment,
and then any pre-lab equations
you think you'll need.
The first pre-lab is due
Monday and Tuesday next week.
That's when the lab
actually will commence.
Tables are very good to
put in your lab notebook
and in your lab reports
as well as drawings
that might help you
to actually visualize
what you're setting up.
For the post-lab,
this is probably
the most detailed
part because you've
got to write everything down
that you're doing in lab,
all your observations,
everything that's happening.
When you're over at
the distillation,
you're going to record the
temperature that the distillate
started to come over.
You're going to record the drops
per minute that's coming over.
All of these notes
go into your lab book
while you're working in the lab.
So let me show you a couple
examples of lab notebooks, what
students have done.
This is one example
where a student had--
sorry-- where a student had put
their pre-lab notes on one side
and left the other side
for their post-lab.
This isn't necessarily
the best way
to do it because you don't
know how much space to leave
for your post-lab.
So another way to
do it would be just
to write out your
pre-lab on one page,
and then stop, and then start
your post-lab on the next page.
The other thing that
comes up is these
are four to five day labs.
So when you read the whole
experiment, one way to do it
is write your lab up
for the whole experiment
all in one time.
Then you don't have to
write it up each time.
That works for a
lot of students.
But we only require you to
write the pre-lab for the day
that you're actually doing.
So I want to talk just a bit
about some questions that
come up a lot, like what is
the stability of my chemicals.
You're going to be
working with some very air
sensitive chemicals.
So you might go over to
the balance area and mass
out your chemical
for the first lab.
You have iron
chloride tetrahydrate.
You mass that out but
then you walk away.
If you don't put the
cover on the chemical,
the green chemical
will turn brown.
And it's not going to be any
good for the other students who
are doing the lab because
the iron gets oxidized.
And you need iron-2
to do the experiment.
So be aware of that.
And then how do I get what I
need from a stock solution?
So you're going to see
chemicals like this labeled
stock solutions for the lab.
The one thing you
don't want to do
is open this up and go
into a stock solution
with a dirty pipette,
because if you
do that, you'll contaminate the
solution for the whole class.
And some of the experiments
are really quantitative
and very sensitive,
especially the Charles River
where we're looking at
the phosphate levels.
So what you want to do is
you want to make sure that--
and the TA should do this--
have these chemicals poured
out in labeled beakers
so that they're ready
for the students
to actually go into and
draw out what they need.
If you don't see that,
always ask your TA.
Never go directly into
the stock solution.
And then the order
in which you add
chemicals is very important.
You always want
to-- you always want
to go from the concentrated
to the less concentrated.
You would never want to
take water and add it
to acid because it would
splash right back in your face.
You always want
to go the reverse.
Add the acid to the water.
Concentrated to
less concentrated.
And if you spill chemicals
while working, let us know.
It's very important.
Don't leave them.
A couple or few years ago,
we had a class during IAP.
And one of the freshmen
spilled a half a bottle of urea
on the floor and left it.
And the TA was beside himself.
He was saying who did this.
Nobody would own up to it.
But we just happened to
be filming this class.
And there is a video online
that you can go watch.
And you can see--
you'll know who it is
when you watch the video.
So you always want
to let us know.
And we always want to clean
up if there is a spill.
And if it's a spill, you have
to let us know right away.
We have to determine
how bad it is
so we don't have to evacuate
the lab or something.
And then if you get
chemicals on yourself,
you know you've got to let
us know because chemicals
on yourself, we can take
care of it right on the spot,
get you washed off.
If we have to, we'll walk
you over to MIT Health
to have them look at it.
And chemical waste.
There are a lot
of different kinds
of waste containers in the lab.
We've got boxes here
for glass and plastic.
And you've got to
look at the box
before you throw something in.
Broken glass would
go in the glass box.
Plastic pipette tips
go in the plastic box.
And make sure that you
empty them of your chemical
first into the waste container
before you throw the pipette's
tips into the box.
There are bottles
for liquid waste.
And everything is labeled.
You can see the red labels here.
A couple of things
you should know.
Don't pour into the top of this.
This is a lid so that
it actually opens up
and then you pour it in.
And then you always have
to close this container
after you've added your waste.
If you leave a waste container
open during an active lab
and we're inspected, MIT can
be fined thousands of dollars.
So you've got to keep the
waste containers closed.
The other thing is you've
got to be aware of what
you're putting in.
So read the container.
Make sure it's the chemical that
you're using that's going in.
You never want to put
acetone in to anything
except a bottle
that says acetone,
because we're going
to be using hydrogen
peroxide in this class.
And hydrogen
peroxide and acetone
and you have an explosion.
So what you're making is
you're actually creating
these acetone peroxy compounds.
This is the dimer.
It's called acetone
peroxide explosive apex.
And then there's also a trimer.
And this is the
triacetone peroxide.
So what happens with
these is they form
a white crystalline powder.
And it smells like bleach.
And when that forms, just any
movement could trigger it.
This is the same stuff that
the shoe bomber had in his shoe
if some of you remember
10 years ago on the plane.
And so it's very frightening.
So you have to be
mindful of what you're
putting in the containers.
The acetone we're
going to recycle.
So it will have containers
just for acetone.
And that's where you're
going to dump it.
The other thing you want to
be aware of is nitric acid.
We're using nitric acid
in the Charles River lab.
You don't want to mix this with
any kind of organic solvents.
If we put this,
say, with ethanol,
then you're making this
C2H5 ethyl nitrate.
And this is also a
primary explosive.
The first thing that
happens is you'll
see orange smoke billowing out.
And then you'll hear
this whining noise.
And it gets louder and louder.
And then the hood goes.
The ceiling goes.
So if you see smoke or you hear
noises, get away from the hood.
But don't put nitric
acid with anything
except in the container
that says nitric acid.
There are also some containers
for solid waste by the scales.
So as you're massing
your chemicals out,
if you have a little
bit left over,
they go in the can with
you with your weigh boats.
Don't put gloves into the cans.
Gloves can go in the trash.
We have a box for needles
here, which is great.
And don't put
needles in the trash,
because the cleaners grab
those trash bags at night
and they could get poked.
And that would not be good.
So the needles, we're going
to try to count them out.
And the TA will be
judicious in coming around
with the needle box and
collect them at the end.
Calibration of melting point.
I just want to show
you one thing here.
If you go to the
melting point and you
take a melting point
of your sample,
an uncalibrated
melting temperature
might be 64 to 66 degrees.
Once it's calibrated, you're
up to 79 to 80.9 degrees.
So we have four standards.
And each standard has a
range where it starts to melt
and ends melting.
So you put your standard in.
Then you look through the scope.
And you record
your observed where
it's melting, when it
started, when it stopped.
And you have two points
for each standard.
So you can do a
linear regression
and draw a straight line and
get an equation for the line.
And then every time that you
use that melting temperature,
you can calculate--
you put in your experimental
and calculate what
it should be from the equation.
So we've got we've got a
couple of minutes left.
And this is a chemistry class.
So I'd like to do a
demonstration just
to end this class.
And I need a volunteer.
Yes.
Come on.
And what is your name?
AUDIENCE: Autumn.
PROFESSOR: Autumn.
OK, Autumn.
So Autumn, I've got a
cup here and some water.
So I'm going to pour
some water into the cup.
And you tell me when to stop.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Stop.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to cover this up.
OK.
And then I'm going to
carefully turn this over.
So far so good, right?
You know where I'm
going with this, Autumn?
I'm going to put
it on your head.
Face your fellow students.
And we'll go up
here very gently.
And there we go.
Now I'm going to let
you hold it, Autumn,
because I don't want
to be responsible.
OK.
You OK so far?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
PROFESSOR: OK.
All right.
Autumn, what does this say?
AUDIENCE: Do not
remove this card.
PROFESSOR: Whoops.
OK.
Let me take this
off from Autumn.
AUDIENCE: What's on my head?
PROFESSOR: What happened
to the water, Autumn?
AUDIENCE: Is there something
inside that absorbed it?
PROFESSOR: She said
is there something
inside that absorbed it?
OK.
Let's see what we got here.
We made a polymer.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
PROFESSOR: So
unbeknownst to Autumn,
I had a little bit
of powder in her cup.
And when I put the water in,
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
AUDIENCE: What kind
of polymer is it?
PROFESSOR: I knew you
were going to ask that.
What kind of polymer is this?
AUDIENCE: I'm Course three.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you'll all know this.
Hold that for a minute, Autumn.
This is the diaper polymer.
This is sodium polyacrylate.
And I actually took
one of these diapers.
And I cut it open.
And I got 4 grams of sodium
polyacrylate out of the diaper.
So this is how they work.
These polymers, you can
see this polyacrylate
is a monomer repeating unit.
And what happens is
if you look inside,
it has a lot of sodiums.
But when we put the
water around it,
it starts to send sodium out
and pull water in by osmosis
to balance the sodium atoms.
So all of a sudden it swells up.
And you've got this system here.
Now we're going to do
a little experiment.
We're going to take this
and put those on now.
OK.
So I'm going to take this and
put it into a little baggy.
Hold that bag.
AUDIENCE: Add salt [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I'm going to
add some salt to this.
And now we're doing the
reverse of what we just did.
We had added water
to the polymer before
but now we're putting salt in.
So just zip that bag up.
And this is the
fun part, Autumn.
You get to squish it around.
So now there are sodium ions
on the outside of the polymer.
And it's panicking.
It's starting to pull them
in and send some of the water
back out.
So the polymer is actually
going back to a liquid.
So that's how this works.
Great.
Give her a hand.
She did a great job.
Thank you so much, Autumn.
Well, thank you all.
And the next lecture is Tuesday.
Don't forget to go to
the safety lecture.
And that is downstairs,
two flights down.